good morning believe nation today's
messages find your path over to you
Marie Forleo you know my first gig out
of college was on Wall Street on the New
York Stock Exchange and this is pre
everything this is like just out of
college 21 years old and I knew one of
my drives I wanted to be really
successful but not just like get shoes I
knew I wanted to make money because I
wanted to make a difference I wanted to
be able to take care of my family I
wanted to be able to contribute to
causes that I believe in and so I knew
in order to do that in my own mind I was
like well I want to make a lot of money
and make this stuff happen but when I
was on Wall Street even though so many
people that I worked with Multi multi
millionaires I mean the money was
ridiculous while they were financially
rich they were spiritually bankrupt and
I felt like there was a part of me that
was dying inside and I said this is not
my path I don't know what my path is but
I need to leave this because I feel sick
and so I think many people feel like
that you can find yourself and job and
job and job and you want to do it really
you want to do great work in the world
you're giving it your best that some
little voice inside is saying this isn't
me this isn't me and I kept having that
voice until finally I left the corporate
world and started my own business for
those of you loyal viewers you've known
that when I was in high school I thought
it was going to be a banker it was in my
high school yearbook and I had the
opportunity to become a banker earn you
know 80 hundred thousand dollars
starting salary at the company that I
wanted to work at and I said no to
become an entrepreneur when I was making
three hundred dollars a month because I
didn't want to live with regret that I
made the wrong decision and and it just
it felt right and I think this is a
challenge for a lot of people because I
feel like people know when something
doesn't feel right I feel like you know
you know I feel like you know somewhere
that this isn't the right thing to do
you're just too scared to do the right
thing where you don't know what the
right thing is
you just know that what you're doing
right now is not the right thing and if
you don't know where to jump to then it
can be really scary and it's having the
courage to move forward on a path that's
unknown versus taking the safe path that
is known but doesn't feel right and I
think that's where most people fall down
like not everybody wants to be an
entrepreneur I get dad is totally cool
but people do have dreams people you
know do have aspirations and they're not
realizing them and they're stuck in a
job that they hate or a life that they
hate or Alysha that they hate or an
environment that they hate because it's
just okay you know it's not bad enough
to make them want to leave but just
because it's okay it means that they
don't strive for something much greater
and if they don't know where they want
to go you don't know you don't have that
clear vision for where you want to go
then it's massively scary to have the
courage to go out and take that leap and
I think one is just having the awareness
and hearing different people say that
you shouldn't settle for a mediocre life
that if you feel like you want to do
something more that you at least owe it
to yourself to do it so you're not that
80 year old sitting back on your
deathbed thinking man I wish I did more
with my life I wish I'd changed my dream
and then to recognize that doesn't have
to be an all-or-nothing thing like if
you don't like your life right now or a
part of it your job or your relationship
or something you don't have to just quit
and then move on to something else I
mean that can work for some people but
I'm in the school of thought of just
start trying stuff part-time like try
for an hour a day it doesn't have to be
something massively radical and crazy
and I think if you can get your head
around that then it reduces the fear
reduces the uncertainty and then
hopefully gets you a little bit excited
because you want to be excited about the
dream thing that you're you're often
chasing and so I would echo the point
that if you are not happy with something
in your life I kind of try to live by
this if I'm not happy with something for
too long my schedule my work environment
something if I'm if I'm not excited not
even not happy if I'm if I'm not
by something for too many days in a row
then something has to change you know I
changed my schedule around constantly I
have some core principles but I'll
change it around based on what's
happened in my life and I don't think
people are static beans like things will
change in your life and if you don't
adapt and grow as things and changing as
you grow then you're gonna feel out of
place then you're gonna feel unhappy and
unsatisfied and so your life is never
perfect
that's just constantly evolving and you
need to catch up to it as you change
that you change your life alongside with
you and stop settling for okay stop
settling for mediocrity stop settling
for just good if you're not happy with
something in your life accept
responsibility and start making some
changes it doesn't have to be all in
just start right now so the question
today is I want to know one area of your
business or your life that you're not
happy with that you're gonna make a
change today with could be a small minor
change at school just you're gonna make
a change right now cuz you're not happy
with it leave in the comments below I'm
gonna join the discussion thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again s'more morning for another shot of
espresso